[Music]
critical phenomena Arise at transitions
the idea is that they want a system is
just at this edge of order and disorder
interesting complex Dynamics can arise
as a physicist critical phenomena is
extremely appealing because it appears
in many phenomena from the evolution of
the universe to the properties of
superconductors flux of Starlings
networks of brain cells tectonic plates
social interactions among humans all
these types of things anytime I can see
one equation applied to lots and lots of
different things I think that's
beautiful it's economical it's
insightful which raises a really
profound question which is why
why are so many things in nature
operating near the critical point
[Music]
when physical systems go through phase
transitions such as when water
transitions from a liquid into a vapor
because of a change in temperature the
system moves through what's known as the
critical point a fleeting moment of
transition from one phase to another
characterized by exotic emergent
properties that have long intrigued
scientists
critical systems have this property of
changing phase and that small changes in
some critical environmental variable
leads to drastic changes almost
discontinuous changes in the function
and it's that kind of observation that
leads us to believe
that the study of critical transitions
is valuable
critical Dynamics are best demonstrated
in a simplified system known as the
izing model which visualizes the
individual iron atoms making up a magnet
with arrows to indicate the direction of
each atom's spin
you can imagine a lattice and on the
slattus you've got all these little
spins that can point either up or down
and when this lattice is really cold
what will happen is all the spins will
line up together so nearest neighbor
interactions will cause them all to
point in the same direction and if this
is a piece of iron uh you know Bing it
would stick on your refrigerator because
all the bar magnets some in the same
direction
but now if you heat this up if you took
a little Bic lighter and you put it
under it what would happen is these
little spins would start moving and
they'd start going in different
directions and then they would
eventually cancel some of them would
point up and half of them would Point
down and it would fall off of your
refrigerator so you get a phase
transition from it being very ordered to
being totally disorder
as it passes from order to disorder the
system moves through the critical point
and clusters of similarly oriented spins
formed throughout the lattice if you
were to measure the sizes of these
clusters at various scales the data
would reveal what's known as a power law
where Dynamics at one scale mirror the
Dynamics at other scales this phenomenon
is also known as scale invariance
scaling variance is another way of
saying that there is self-similarity or
fractality if you want
this kind of properties are spectacular
because indeed it's like everything
simplifies at the critical point
when a system reaches the critical point
it displays a Telltale peak in what's
known as the correlation length an
indication of how sensitive the system
as a whole is to the activity of any one
of its components what happens is the
system behaves in ways that allow
fluctuations to occur over the scale of
the entire system if it was too cold
you'd have no correlation because
they're just pointing they're not moving
and when it's too hot they're moving a
lot but they're not correlated so only
at that sweet spot right in the middle
do you have interactions at all scales
now what that means is something very
weird that means that the distance over
which these spins might interact is
technically infinite I could take a spin
over here and flip it and there's some
non-zero probability that another spin
very very far away would flip also as a
result of it
[Music]
in 1987 the physicist purbach wondered
if many different types of complex
systems in the natural world might
self-organize around critical points
to illustrate his theory of
self-organized criticality Bach used The
Familiar example of a sand pile
as the pile gains Mass friction can no
longer hold the grains of sand in place
and a single grain added to the pile
will trigger an outsized effect sending
Avalanches cascading down its sides and
it turns out that if you look at the
distribution of Avalon sizes the big
ones the small ones intermediate ones
they follow power laws and so per box
idea was that hey here's a natural
system that self-organizes to the
critical point you don't need to tune it
there you don't need to get just the
right control temperature it will evolve
into that state and so when he came out
with this concept of self-organized
criticality he was claiming that many
natural systems fall into that category
like earthquakes
like stock market crashes
like piles of sand
now he was a Pioneer and it was amazing
that he did that and it inspired many
people from other areas to enter into
the field of criticality and to take a
look at this concept and apply it more
generally and and I would say basically
it's had huge amounts of traction
however
there have been people who have been
quite skeptical
box equations only account for one grain
of sand hitting the pile at a time in
nature things are more complicated and
researchers have found it difficult to
simulate criticality and this is a
general problem of mathematical models
just to be always aware of which is at
what point have you overextended that
simple abstraction and applied it in a
way that's inadmissible and so SOC is
just one mechanism for tuning to
critical points it's a very interesting
one but perhaps it will turn out to be a
rare one
foreign
despite the criticism box work inspired
interest and criticality throughout the
1990s and into the early 2000s when
neuroscientists began to probe a new
question whether brains might exhibit
self-organized criticality
her box work opened up the concept
the criticality could apply to many
different things and that made me think
oh we've got lots of neurons that are
interacting in this network so hey why
not so we just started to apply that
framework to the data the idea that the
brain is at a transition point for
example at criticality at the transition
between Order and Chaos and it had been
around for a while I think the real
Avalanche of criticality research was
triggered by John Banks and did my
plants in 2003.
we isolated in this case the gray matter
the cortex has a piece of tissue when it
was young we grew it on a microelectrode
array in a dish it let it grow for about
four weeks and we measure the activity
how these cells would interact with each
other and we we found
that they start to form groups like just
these Cascades that were predicted by
the probation and so I started plotting
Avalanche size distributions and sure
enough they were power law
it was the first paper that claimed that
the brain was probably functioning at
the critical point
the question for scientists then became
why why might functioning at a critical
point be helpful for brains
can you show that operating near the
critical point actually increases
behavioral performance and when you're
not near the critical point it doesn't
so why would being at the critical point
be to your evolutionary advantage
so let's say you're I don't know and at
the side of a river and there's a bunch
of reeds and they're blowing in the wind
but you notice that hey this is
different from yesterday I think there's
a tiger back there
so you want to be very sensitive to
inputs the system is most susceptible to
Smite slight changes in inputs when it's
near the critical point it has these
large fluctuations that can take off
according to the critical brain
hypothesis when the network is right at
criticality it's perfectly balanced
between two extreme states
super criticality in which networks of
neurons display the highly ordered
runaway excitation seen in epilepsy
and sub-criticality in which signals
fail to trigger larger Cascades and
stall out as seen in comatose States
by hovering near the critical point the
theory goes networks of neurons would be
optimized for information transmission
just like in the ising model tiny inputs
could result in big complex behaviors in
the network
proving that such a measurement of
optimal brain activity exists would give
researchers a new scale to interpret
just about everything brains do
when we first got our results back from
the 2003 paper uh I was just enamored
with the idea of criticality I was in
love with it I'd go to bed thinking oh
it's optimal information transmission
we've got the just the right exponents
it's all cool and then over time people
started to question this in various ways
just as with per box and pile model
scientists began to question whether the
physics of criticality could neatly
apply to such a chaotic biological
system with so many variables
interacting all at once in simpler
systems like the ising model a single
variable like temperature can be
adjusted to bring the network right to
the critical point but in complex
biological systems the prospect of
tuning to the exact point of criticality
would be much more difficult the brain
is constantly receiving inputs from
outside that could you know blow it off
of the critical point so for those
reasons alone it can't really be exactly
critical
then what is it
one of the options of many on the menu
about how the brain is actually
operating is that it's slightly so
critical
that it doesn't really get to the
critical point because that might be
dangerous
another plausible idea is that it's
quasi-critical and what that means is
that it gets as close to the critical
point as it can but then there's this
activity that's basically going to push
it away from being right at the critical
point as research continues to reveal
tantalizing signatures of criticality
what was once a fringe theory has begun
to attract more mainstream attention in
the field with researchers now hunting
for what kinds of mechanisms might be
responsible for tuning brains towards
the critical point
the big question that is an answer
so far is what is the homeostatic
mechanism bringing back the brain to
this quasi-criticality region that's a
big question is the big open question
that's a million dollar question
[Music]
Neuroscience has been and continues to
be very hesitant and reluctant to agree
on a theoretical idea of the kind that
criticality offers
most neuroscientists are very hard-nosed
empiricists they don't believe that
there is an overarching theory that
explains most or God forbid all of the
what the brain is doing in one handy
concept such as critical state
I personally
um think that what what does not play
well with neuroscientists is if
criticality is portrayed as the answer
to everything
and I think that that is overselling it
and yet I have no doubt believing that a
system like the brain almost requires to
be in a critical state for it to
function well or optimally even
there might be one equation that
explains how the whole thing works
that's the the idealized dream
we may never ever get there but the hope
is that there might be some general
principles that really explain how
intelligence functions in this world
that we live in the field wasn't there
20 years ago when we had just one idea a
sandpile model or an icing model that
would guide us we are way beyond that
and we are at the point now where
the technological advance in
Neuroscience to record individual
spiking activity from many many
thousands of neurons these are the
precision tools that we need in order to
test new ideas on critical
how is the collective coming together to
produce outcomes that are Way Beyond
what an individual can do and I think
this is how our society is organized
our brain our body is organized and any
understanding of the enrichness that we
gain when we operate as a collective I
think is just beautiful scientific
insight
foreign
[Music]